the law explicitly and repeatedly States
subsidies are only available in
exchanges established by a state what
Robert said basically was that they're
now available in an exchange established
by a state or the federal government he
added to the law Roberts's decision
basically says that Congress didn't
intend for any adverse policy effects
that come from the law and so the
Supreme Court's job is to make sure that
none come Roberts frames his opinion as
a kind of deference to Congress saying
we don't want to do too much damage to
what they intended we have to respect
that but in a lot of ways what he really
did was choose what Congress meant and
decide that for them right now a lot of
states are struggling with technology
that doesn't work and with trying to
find ways to make the financing for
their own exchanges sustainable and
Roberts decision paves the way for them
to move over to the federal exchange and
solve some of their problems that way
for the most part Roberts decision
simply preserves the status quo at its
most basic this was a decision to allow
things to say basically the same